well my friends if you're hearing this  message and it is a special message it  is uh because we are at the start of my  paternity leave yes  it's been  i mean it feels like it's been three  years of pregnancy for my fiance  but i'm told it's been like nine and a  half months but it i'm telling you it's  it's been like three years in my head  uh that phase  is coming to an end and i am going to be  taking a little bit of time off if you  want to follow the news and adventure at  some point i will post something to my  social media  but uh who knows what it's going to be  like on the other side so we've got some  great uh themed episodes coming up for  you we've got a lot of different things  planned  the news will continue and we will be  here with you in one form or another  and then eventually i'm going to be back  it's quite exciting times  2022 all of these incredible things  and  i will be back with everybody